[Applause]
here's the question everyone's been
wondering for the past few days what
would happen if both North Korea and
South Korea merged into one single
nation yes I know this isn't something
that's gonna have it in the near future
but it certainly is a possibility and
one that nice actually happened sooner
than we expect just one year ago nobody
would have predicted that now in the
spring of 2018 Kim jong-un would shake
hands with the South Korean presidents
moon jae-in so what would a Korean
reunification look like the truth is
there is historical precedent for all of
this yes my dear viewers of course I'm
talking about German reunification as
you may remember Germany used to be
divided into two separate countries an
eastern bloc with a socialist communist
regime and the Western bloc with a
capitalist system
[Music]
then the Berlin Wall came down and East
Germany was absorbed by West Germany and
since then the government has spent lots
of money so that the eastern Germans
could enjoy a similar lifestyle to the
wealthy of Western Germans many experts
consider this a success story
some of them claimed that this could be
a model for what the integration of
North and South Korea might look like I
mean think about it in both cases
there's capitalism and socialism in both
cases one side is poor while the other
side is wealthy and in both cases they
share a common language common history
and a common culture but now the
question is was the German reunification
as successful as it looks on paper can
we say East Germans today are doing as
well as their Western neighbors well the
answer's no even in saco we can see
small differences since Germany was
reunited there have been no eastern
teams in the Bundesliga since 2009 the
Western teams still dominate the
national sport in fact there is only one
East German team in the Bundesliga the
RB likes you but it's just one team in a
soccer league of over 18 teams and the
same applies in economics but where the
differences turn more scary is when we
talk about politics for example in the
last election the radical right-wing aft
has entered the Parliament as the third
largest party this radical
anti-immigrant entire a skeptic party
has gained the majority of its vote from
regions in the former East Germany this
has marked the first time since 1961
that a far-right party has said this
kind of presence in German parliaments
and that of viewers is actually pretty
frightening
venj of the east how anger in former GDR
helped the AFD so the real question here
is this is the process of reunification
done what can we learn from Germany if
it could be applied to North and South
Korea
well today we aren't going to answer
this question but before we do let's
take a look back at the history to the
victors go the spoils after its
unconditional surrender the Allies
divided Germany into four military
occupation zones Britain in the
northwest France in the southwest the
USA in the south and the Soviet Union in
the East there's a lot more we could say
about this time but we're not going to
go into every little detail because well
if we did you'd be staring at my face
for a couple of hours but suffice it to
say that from 1949 Germany was
transformed into two different countries
West Germany officially known as the
Federal Republic of Germany with on as
its capital and East Germany whose
official name was the Democratic
Republic of Germany with its capital in
East Berlin so East Germany was the
communist region while West Germany
became the embodiment of its capitalist
occupants while West Berlin started to
look more and more like a big city would
in the United States East Berlin became
Moscow's carbon-copy
according to East Germany's first
constitution its citizens enjoyed
certain basic rights even the rights to
strike but in reality there was little
freedom all policy related matters were
decided by the police Bureau the
Executive Committee of the socialist
Unity Party and the main and almost only
source of information in the country was
directly financed by the only party
here's a great example of just how
unbiased it was in Germany the central
organ of the socialist Unity Party
celebrating 100 years of the Communist
Manifesto East Germany's economy as you
may have already guessed was centrally
planned and almost completely owned by
the state the central government set the
price of housing basic goods and even
services so basically every year the
government would publish a list with the
mandatory prices of every basic good
you'd want to buy a bread roll 5 marks a
thousand marks for a Sony Walkman and so
on and so forth even if you had the
money they were waiting lists in place
for goods like cars and electronics I
mean who really wants to wait 10 years
to get a Travon car take the
unemployment generated by these strict
price control take all of those empty
supermarkets take the scarcity of
primary basic goods and pair those with
elements like a low birthrate and guess
what you get you got lots and lots of
people who want to escape East Germany
so what are these to government do about
this well they built a wall to stop
people leaving the country in order to
justify this move the official state
propaganda claims that they were
building the wall to protect their
country from fascist infiltration but
the actual reason was exactly the
opposite as you can imagine what with
having a literal wall between them the
relationship between East and West
Germany wasn't exactly friendly
in fact West Germany didn't even
recognize the East German government
because they claimed to be the only
legitimate state for all Germans and the
East did the same thing now this might
actually remind you of something yes
it's more or less the relationship that
the two Koreas have with each other
although in the former case there were
no nuclear bombs involved and just like
North and South Korea are reaching an
agreement East and West Germany
normalized their relations in the 1970s
but the real twist in history that came
in the year 1989 almost no one could
have anticipated that the 40th
anniversary of the GDR would also be
it's lost and that Germany would be
reunited once more but then history
found a way to surprise us all the speed
at which these changes occurred was
astounding only 10 months after the fall
of the wall East and West Germany would
become a single nation
the new Germany is here Secretary of
State James a baker the third set
let our legacy be that after 45 years we
finally got the political arithmetic
right two plus four adds up to one
Germany in a Europe whole and free but
make no mistake this was not a merger
between two countries this was a
complete absorption basically on October
3rd 1990 East Germany disappeared as an
independent country and became a part of
West Germany and this was definitely a
good move but it did have some downsides
[Music]
reunited at last so the two states were
one once more but not everything was
exactly sunshine and rainbows here a
West Germany was extremely wealthy and
has high productivity and was very
industrialized East Germany was the
opposite
the soviet-controlled state and lower
productivity less wealth and a totally
different political system again this
was a very similar starting point to
that of North and South Korea although
less extreme but the process to be
successful the two states needed to
somehow find a way to unify they're two
completely different structures so now
the question probably in your mind is
well what exactly did they do well
basically West Germany exported all of
their laws their taxes and their
regulations to East Germany
[Music]
in exchange they also took care of all
the infrastructure costs this means that
the Western taxpayers would pay for the
highways the railroads and the streets
of eastern Germany and now I know what
you're probably thinking right now this
sounds pretty fair right I mean if you
want to join your poorer neighbor to
create a bigger country you kind of have
to help them recover but economics is
way more complicated than just pouring
money into something basically the
reunification meant the total collapse
of the whole eastern economy and why was
this well just think about it I mean
having a single country means having a
single market - a single market where
Western companies were several times
more productive than their Eastern
counterparts so Eastern factories they
just couldn't compete for example East
Germany produced the famous Travon car
and he compared with a BMW or an Audi a
travel it's just a toy so the demand for
those cars well it just dropped by for
day
many refugees hoping to settle in the
West dump their communist built vehicles
near the West Germany Embassy in Prague
all right
so imagine the situation you work in a
Travon factory - the company has to
close because nobody's buying their cars
then you go to the supermarket and
everything you want to buy is produced
in the West because well they have the
best factories but then again everything
is more and more expensive because well
surprise all of a sudden you live in a
rich country with really high prices and
this isn't the end of the story here I
mean imagine you're an old man in the
east and you get a pension that's
calculated based on the prices during
communist times but now it's 1990 and
you go to the CY and the bread has a
Western price which is triple
I mean you can probably see where I'm
going with this young people I mean at
least they could emigrate and believe me
they did but what could the elderly do
and just hold on a second now because on
top of all that we have the currency
exchanges you see the two countries
they're different currencies with
different values so how did they make it
work well the finance ministers of
eastern and western Germany they met in
room and they decided on a fixed
exchange rate between the West German
mark and the East German mark the public
demanded a one-to-one exchange and on
July the 1st 1990 the banks in the
former Eastern Germany provided people
with the unbelievable exchange rate of
one to one I say this is in quite Marx
because the theory was one thing and the
reality was quite another most of the
banks would sell you one Western mark
for two eastern ones this is an exchange
rate of two to one and on the black
market that exchange rate would be
anywhere from 8 to 1 to 12 to 1 so from
one day to the next all the money that
you had in your savings would lose half
of its value
so well now you might be wondering what
what did the German government do to
manage this situation well the answer is
subsidies subsidies and hope are more
subsidies West German taxpayers paid
medical bills infrastructure and they
were doing everything they could to
prevent eastern Germans from migrating
we're talking about almost 70 billion
u.s. dollars every single year since
1990 that is the equivalent of
organizing four Olympic Games every
single yeah so now I know what you're
wondering after almost 30 years is this
reunification process done can we say
that Germany is now an equal country
well dear viewer the answer is yes
and also no
[Music]
together but not mixed according to one
study a good share of German state that
they wouldn't marry somebody from the
other Germany 3/4 of the German
population thing there are still
different mentalities between the east
and the west and 10% of East Germans
have never once traveled to the other
side and of course there are still
differences in economic terms if you
look at this chart you can see that at
the time of reunification the GDP per
capita in the East was nine thousand
four hundred euros as compared to
twenty-two thousand euros in the West
today it's 27 thousand euros and 41
thousand euros yes the difference is a
more subtle but nobody can seriously
claim that there are no differences and
of course we still have the cultural
differences a research study done by
Jacob University in Bremen measured
community spirits considering a number
of factors including trust in
institutions and tolerance towards the
LGBTQ community as well as ethnic
minorities all the regions the ones made
up
East Germany appeared in the bottom half
of the index
[Music]
and finally we have the political
differences that we can see in the
latest elections eastern Germans voted
for a FD a far-right wing party and D
linka a far left-wing party while
western Germans chose more moderate
candidates this divided in the polls
shows how still to this day stand
Germans are heavily influenced by
Russian politics this is important
because one day Eastern Germans could
hijack German politics and destroy that
sense of German moderation now going
back to the case of North Korea imagine
what would happen if North Koreans kept
voting for communist parties I mean all
of a sudden you have a leader like Kim
Jong and making decisions that also
affect South Koreans which kind of
sounds pretty scary now of course there
are many bright sides to the German
reunification and as we've mentioned in
many of our videos here at visual
politic Germany is still a model for
other countries but as we always say not
everything is perfect and if there has
to be a Korean reunification one day it
will not come without risks
[Music]
but now it's your turn do you think the
eastern Germans could radicalize the
political debate in Germany do you still
feel that German reunification could be
a model
for the Korean Peninsula well please
leave your answer in the comment section
below and of course don't forget to
visit our friends from the reconsidered
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this video that were not mine and if
you liked this video we publish brand
new ones every week so hit that
subscribe button and you won't miss a
single post and as always see you next
time and if you want to learn more about
politics and here even more of my lovely
voice you can join us at reconsider
media we have a podcast at reconsider
mediacom slash podcast see you there